okay today I'm going to talk to you
about changes of state we're going to
talk to about solids liquids and gases
and the transitions between each one
what's happening to the particles what's
happening the amount of energy and what
are these key terms called
so whenever it's we're thinking about
change of state it's really really
useful to think about water because the
terms that we're using today we use in
our everyday language so first of all
let's imagine turning from a solid into
a liquid so for example from ice into
water liquid water so in order to do
that we need to heat this solid up we
need to give it give the particles more
energy as we heat this solid the
particles vibrate more so initially they
vibrate more this is what causes that
object to expand slightly now if we give
it enough heat energy enough thermal
energy we're going to give the air
particles enough energy to overcome the
forces between the different particles
so tell you from a solid to a liquid
like ice to water liquid water is called
melting so now these particles are free
to move they're no longer in fixed
positions so again if we wanted to
change a liquid to a gas or a liquid
water to steam or water vapor what we'd
have to do is heat up this liquid even
more so again we're giving it more
energy by giving each particle more
energy we are giving them enough energy
to overcome the forces between these
different particles so as a result we
have a process called evaporating so
again just imagine when you heat up
water in a kettle we're giving those
particles so much energy that we see
steam coming out of the kettle again
evaporating think of these terms relate
to water because it really helps us
imagine the different names of these
changes of state now let's imagine we
want to go the other way let's say we've
got a gas and we want to turn it to a
liquid so instead of giving the
particles
more energy we want to give the
particles less energy so essentially we
need to cool them down so this turning
from a gas to a liquid is called
condensing just like let's say if you've
got out of the shower and there was
steam so water vapor when it touches the
cold mirror call them mirror these
particles lose energy and they condense
they turn into a liquid so because the
particles lose energy they start to slow
down they've got less kinetic energy and
they start to forces get established
between the different particles as those
forces increase it turns from a gas into
a liquid so by removing energy cooling
it down so the next one we're looking at
is between a liquid and a solid so again
let's imagine the example using water of
turning from water liquid water into ice
so that process as we all know is called
freezing so what we're doing to turn
something from a liquid to a solid is
we're giving these particles even less
energy if they've got even less energy
they're moving around less and forces
forces could be established which hold
these particles in place in a fixed
position so again by removing energy is
by having even less energy they turn
from a liquid to a solid so whenever we
we heat up particles shown by everything
in red here give them more energy we
have more each particle has more energy
and it allows them it allows them to
overcome forces so it allows them to
kind of give them enough energy so they
can overcome the forces between these
particles here whenever we have cooling
down we have we're giving them less
energy and this means we can establish
more forces between the different
particles now the final thing I'm
briefly going to mention
there's another change of state certain
substances can go straight from a solid
to a gas that process is called
sublimation so just to summarize to
change state from a solid to a liquid is
called melting you give the particles
more energy to turn a substance we're
liquid to a gas is called evaporating
again you give the particles more energy
and these forces are overcome and the
particles are spread out in order to
turn a gas to a liquid is called
condensing and you need to give up with
less energy by cooling it down we start
to getting more force between the
particles and finally decide from a
liquid to a solid it's called freezing
again less energy by cooling it down and
then we have as forces established
between each particles between all the
different particles thank you very much